welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some big MCU news that could hint at the
return of danos throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down a
deleted Avengers and game scene that
hints at how he can come back as well as
giving our theories on what could be
going on with the character this is a
really fun theory that's just started
picking up a lot of steam and obviously
I'd loved here you were thoughts in the
comments below now there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you're one of the
people that got dusted during the snap
and haven't had a chance to check out
the movie yet then this is your time to
turn off we'll be still here though then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you subscribe to the channel for marble
videos every week without the way thank
you for clicking this let's get into our
breakdown white Thanos could come back
to the MCU
okay so Avengers infinity war ended with
Danis collecting all six Infinity stones
and then carrying out the snap that
would end half of all life in the
universe it's follow-up Avengers endgame
send it around the surviving heroes
collecting the stones once more and at
the end of the movie they reverse the
snap to bring everyone back now pay
attention to this because it becomes
important later and it sort of sets up
the rules for exactly how things could
work after Hulk carried out the snap
though it did seem like things were
going to be all sunshine and rainbows
the 2014 version of Thanos
came through the quantum realm on a
quest to once more take the stones only
this time he was gonna end all life and
start anew which yeah can we do that
because 2020 sucks anyway the heroes
most notably Ironman managed to defeat
Thanos by carrying out their own snap
which dusted the villain in his army the
Adonis initially seems like he's fully
dead and gone when we think about how
the rules of the snap operate it becomes
clear that he's actually not now I did a
tweet about this last week and discussed
how if it's possible to bring back those
that have been dusted then surely Thanos
can come back too well coincidentally
there's actually a deleted scene from
Avengers endgame which is slowly
starting to circulate online that seems
to back this up we can't play the scene
here because of copyright reasons
if you want to check it out it's
available in full on Disney plus the
scene titled Hulk meets the ancient one
plays out much like how the one in the
final cut does however it has some
additional dialogue in which the
sorcerer supreme states how the snap
actually worked and what it did
she says that Dan'l's didn't actually
kill anyone he just willed them out of
existence and that it is possible to
bring people back should enough will be
forced through in an equal and opposite
reaction the full quote by the character
is if someone dies they will always die
death is irreversible but then us not
those you've lost are not dead they've
been willed out of existence they can be
willed back but it doesn't come cheap
she then goes on to explain the
branching timelines that we saw in the
movie but this statement does have a lot
to take from it this confirms that
Thanos is not actually dead and instead
he simply been wheeled out of existence
so we can take from this that it is
possible that anyone who is killed
during a snap can be brought back and
all it requires is the will power to do
so then I'll snow tably said that he was
the only person that possessed the will
to end half of all life in the universe
and thus we can take from this that if
someone has the drive to do something
with the stones they can so
hypothetically if one were to reverse
the snap carried out by Tony then Thanos
could indeed return along with his army
and forces now what this does is that it
opens the character up to be able to
return should a villain or even hero
wish to bring him back this creates
several avenues for his resurrection and
the new Disney plus scene definitely has
a lot to impac from it
there were currently rumors floating
around that Dennis will be returning in
the Eternals and though this is just
thought to be a cameo at the start in
which we see a younger version of the
character down the line Marvel may wish
to bring him back fully I would love it
if he was brought in to fight Galactus
or another villain and it would be great
to see him teaming up with the Avengers
though with him still wanting to pretty
much wipe out all life in the galaxy I
really can't see it but yeah he could
come back now this doesn't open the door
for other characters to return as the
ancient one does say that if someone
dies they will always die that death
irreversible so now we probably won't be
seeing Tony Stark back it also explains
how Hulk was unable to bring Black Widow
back and she had to fully sacrifice
herself in order to get the soul stone
whether she's gonna return after the
events of her solo movie is a matter for
another video but those are the rules
and how they stand at the moment however
Thanos didn't actually fully die and he
could indeed return should the studio
need him for a plotline now another
theory that I had dropped on one of my
videos that I haven't been able to stop
thinking about comes from the docking
the user said that it is possible that
dannis created a fake reality in which
the Avengers thought that they won and
this has just made me question
absolutely everything potentially it
could have happened all the way back in
infinity war after Thanos carried out
the snap he could have gone to the
garden kept the gauntlet and then when
the group arrived to seek vengeance in
endgame
they simply walked into an illusion in
which they killed him much like how
Gamora did in the prior movie he could
have also taken the goal at the end of
endgame and when wearing it decided that
he would just create a fake alternate
version of the truth in which the
Avengers would I know it's probably not
true as strange you would have seen all
this and it's unlikely that Marvel would
want to ruin the highest-grossing movie
of all time but these things they are
they are fun to think about what if 2020
is just fake darkness reality what in
summary though Thanos is indeed still
able to come back another character has
been wheeled out of existence that
doesn't mean he can't be willed back I
guess
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these theories and if you
want to see the big bad of the Marvel
Universe back with the land of the
living
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the entire MCU infinite
you saw a timeline which is going to be
linked at the end we go over the entire
chronology of the movie scene by scene
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch if you
want to support a channel from as little
as 99 cents a month then please click
the join button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people our subscribe to the channel and
this month e can win the MC u infinity
saga box set and all you had to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos he comment on the more you have a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of July and the set
will be shipped out from then to ever
get to the prize it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you